ahora de nuevo tenemos aquí una
expresión bastante peluda y tu meta es
intentar simplificar esto lo más posible
te daré un poco de tiempo para que lo
intentes
entonces bueno simplemente pensemos en
esto paso a paso tal vez puede ayudar si
ordenamos los términos en esta expresión
así que bueno que te así primero pongo
los términos que tienen x tengo 5x es
este término y luego menos 2x ajay ahora
los que tienen más 7 y
y más 3g
luego tengo tengo 8 z + 8 z y tengo
menos z finalmente tengo este este 5
entonces ahora sólo pensemos un poco si
yo tengo 5 x tengo 5 letras x y le quitó
2 x cuántas x me van a quedar cuantas
cuantas me quedan me quedan 3 x ahora no
hay un truco aquí no estamos aplicando
como magia algebraica no simplemente
tiene 5 cosas iguales si le quitas dos
de esas cosas te quedarán tres cosas
iguales entonces en este caso esas cosas
son equis y se simplificará esto a 3x
ahora hay muchas clases de álgebra
escucharás decir a muchos de ciro es que
el coeficiente en 5 x 5 y el coeficiente
en menos 12 x es este menos 2 y lo que
hicimos fue sumar los coeficientes
escribir esa palabra aquí estos son
coeficientes son los números que están
multiplicando a la variable entonces son
el 5 y el menos
en este caso tu puedes pensar bueno yo
sumo los coeficientes y eso es correcto
no hay nada malo en eso pero si quieres
enfatizar en la idea es simplemente
decir yo tengo 5 de algo y le quitó 2 de
ese algo me quedarán 3 de ese algo
cierto simplemente tengo 5 le quito 2 y
me quedan 3 pero debes tener mucho
cuidado porque debes asegurarte de estar
sumando restando las mismas cosas
términos semejantes aquí estamos
trabajando con las equis primero
entonces podemos tener 5x y quitarle 2x
no podemos pensar en las x con las lleno
podemos juntarlas porque eso francamente
no tendría mucho sentido pero ahora
vamos ahora vamos con las yes aquí yo
tengo 7 de algo más 3 de ese algo
entonces tendré 10 de ese algo por lo
tanto esta parte de aquí se
simplificarán a 10 sep y una vez más
podría decir que el coeficiente en 77 el
coeficiente entre sí es 3 entonces lo
suma 7 + 3 10 obtienes 10 james pero lo
mismo si tú tienes 7 de algo le agregas
ese algo obtienes 10 de ese algo ahora
vamos con las setas vamos con las setas
tengo 8 de algo y le quito 1 de ese algo
entonces tendré 7 de ese algo entonces
es 7 z y tal vez te preguntes bueno y
que cuál es el coeficiente en este menos
z porque hay no ves un número pero
implícitamente puedes poner un 1 ahí es
lo mismo entonces restar una zeta es lo
mismo que restar 1 zeta y puedes ver que
en efecto tú has restado los
coeficientes 8 y menos 1 pero en sentido
común lo que haces es tú tienes 8 de
algo y le quitas 1 de ese algo tienes
entonces 7 de ese algo y ahora
finalmente tenemos en + 5 y terminamos
esta esto se simplifica a 3 x + dj más 7
z más 5 ahí está